Let's say that I
have the matrix A.
And we know we denote matrices
with bolded capital letters.
So I have the matrix A.
And it is a 3 by 2 matrix.
And so let's say it's 1,
negative 2, 3, 0, 7, 5.
It's a 3 by 2 matrix.
And what my question
to myself-- or to you,
if you're listening-- is
what is the transpose of A?
And so we denote the
transpose like this,
A with this little
superscript T right over here.
And all this is talking about
is the transpose of matrix A.
And so your natural
question should
be, well, what does it mean to
take the transpose of a matrix?
It sounds very fancy.
Well, it is not that fancy.
All this means is
rows become columns.
And you could imagine, when
the rows become columns,
the columns become the rows.
What do I mean by that?
Well, let's do it
right over here.
So if I have three rows.
So let's be clear.
This is one, two, three rows.
So this is three rows
by one, two columns.
So this is a 3 by 2 matrix.
If all the rows are
going to become columns
and all the columns are
going to become rows,
the transpose is going
to be a 2 by 3 matrix.
It's going to be two rows.
The two columns here are
going to become the two rows,
by three columns.
These three rows are going
to become three columns.
And so it's going
to look something
like-- let me do it
in that blue color.
It's going to have two rows now.
And it's going to
have three columns.
So I said all the
rows became columns.
All the columns became rows.
Well, I could view
it exactly like that.
I have this first row
here of 1, negative 2.
I can turn that into my first
column now of 1, negative 2.
I have the second row, 3 and 0.
That will be now my
second column, 3 and 0.
And I have this
third row, 7 and 5.
Well, that's going to be my
third column now, 7 and 5.
And you could have
just as easily viewed
it the other way around.
You could say, look,
I have two columns.
My first column is 1, 3, 7.
So my first row now is
going to be 1, 3, 7.
And then you could say, my
second column is negative 2,
0, 5.
And so my second row
will be negative 2, 0, 5.
Let's do another
example of that,
just so we really make it clear.
So let's say I
have matrix B. Once
again, bolded capital letter.
And let's just say it's a
really simple 2 by 2 matrix.
So it's negative 1, 5,
pi, and 3 are its entries.
What is B transpose
going to be equal to?
Well, once again, we have
two rows and two columns.
So if all the rows become
columns and all the columns
become rows, I'm still going
to have a 2 by 2 matrix.
But we just have to say,
look, my first row here
is negative 1, 5.
So that's now going to be my
first column, negative 1 and 5.
I have my second row
here, which is pi and 3.
So now that's going to become
my second column of pi and 3.
And so I have taken
the transpose.
All the rows became columns.
All the columns became rows.